hello everyone and welcome back to the F
Grand Swiss we have an excellent game
between jaok synov and vid garati COV
just defeated at Samuel seian we've seen
how he did it in the previous video with
the black pieces it was absolutely
incredible uh can he use some of that
complicated chest to take down a 2700
player like vidit Gujarati so let's
check it out COV has the white pieces
and he opens with Pawn to E4 uh we have
Pawn to E5 Knight to F3 Knight to C6 and
Bishop to C4 we have Bishop to C5 going
for the Joo piano uh and now Pawn to D3
uh some players from usbekistan have
been um seen playing the Evans Gambit so
I thought maybe jaer will will go for it
but no he goes for D3 the jimo variation
uh D6 and C3 and here uh there are a lot
of moves that are possible and that are
played like Bishop to G4 Knight to F6 is
played here even H6 is played here some
other moves as well but here we have
Bishop back to B6 it's a very rare move
but it has been used by Wesley so to
defeat none other than ala fuja in this
year's Super bit chess classic uh so
obviously it can be played we have
castles and now Knight to F6 we have
Pawn to A4 preparing uh to advance those
pawns even further so Pawn to A5
stopping B4 and Bishop to E3 uh
countering the strong dark Square Bishop
so we have a trade captures captures and
here we have Castle's King side Knight B
to two and now there is a game where
Queen to A7 was played but here we have
Knight to E7 by vidit and it is now as
of move 10 that we have a completely new
game uh so okay Knight to H4 the Knight
of course wants to come to F5 and you
cannot prevent it with G6 for the moment
as the Knight on F6 would be undefended
so here we have Pawn to D5 instead you
could also prepare it with Pawn to C6 V
it decides to go for it right away e
captures on D5 we have Knight E captures
on D5 and now Queen to f F3 as Knight
captures on E3 is a threat even if you
play E4 Knight to E3 is still a threat
so Queen F3 and now Knight to B6 uh very
annoying putting pressure on the light
Square Bishop you can't really move it
back as the D3 Pawn would fall so we
have Pawn to
E4 uh the queen now guarding the D3 pawn
and queen to D6 now we have Queen back
to E2 and Bishop to G4 attacking the
queen so okay you made room for the
Knight on F3 and now Rook 8 to d8
putting more pressure on that D3 Pawn we
have Pawn to H3 Bishop to H5 and now
completely unpinning with Bishop with
Pawn to G4 uh Bishop to G6 and now Rook
F to D1 adding more support to the D
Pawn uh Knight F to D7 preparing Knight
to C5 to add more pressure to the D3
pawn and now Bishop to B3 finally so
what's the idea uh behind this bishop to
B3 maneuver is um uh the D3 Pawn for the
moment is defended as the Knight was
placed on D7 so so it disconnected the
queen and the Rook uh but now comes
Knight to C5 and now there's a trip
attack on the bishop and a triple attack
on the D3 Pawn so we have Knight to C4
attacking the black queen and queen to
F6 and now H although it seems like you
should play Bishop to C2 at add more
support here the move is actually Bishop
to A2 if you play this then uh Knight
captures on C4 and your entire Pawn
structure is completely messed up if
Queen to B6 putting pressure on the King
on G1 uh threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries and also threatening Queen
captur some B2 you cannot even save it
with with something like Queen E3 to put
pressure on the Knight because still
Queen captures on B2 happens and now if
you capture on C5 then the black queen
just gobbles up the bishop and now look
at White's Pawn structure it would be it
would be just unplayable so instead
Bishop to A2 is the only move that keeps
jaok in the game uh Rook F to E8 and now
we have King to G2 we have Knight B
captures on A4 giving up the uh the um a
pawn for the Central Pawn Pawn to H4 now
threatening to uh to trap the bishop on
G6 and now Queen to F4 now can you trap
the bishop here well not really as the
G4 Pawn is hanging so here we have
Knight C captures on E5 while capturing
also defending the pawn on G4 uh Rook
captures on E5 uh giving up sort of The
Rook for two knights but um jaok is of
course hoping that he will still trap
the Bishop with H5 however uh that's not
going to happen Knight captures on E5
Queen captures and pawn to H5 but now uh
Rook captures on D3 and look at this
very annoying move now if you don't do
anything also Bishop captures on on e4
is now possible there's no D3 Pawn
defending that E4 Pawn so the kind the
entire game is basically the battle for
for the D3 pawn and in the end vid it
emerges on top and now if you go for
Bishop captures um if you go for H
captures Bishop with h captures on G6
then just Queen G3 check and now you
will lose the queen after Rook to F3 the
White Queen will have to sacrifice
itself for The Rook on F3 so instead
after Rook captures on D3 jav's only
idea is Bishop captures on F7 uh but vid
doesn't uh take it although you could
take King to f8 is just more precise and
now we have Rook captures on D3 and it
seems like white solved all of his
problems but there is one move that
completely shatters um uh White wise
game so feel free to pause the video and
try to find this only move while I give
you a couple of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on not
going for anything weird like Bishop
captures on e4 and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Knight
captures on D3 that's the move even
though it seems like Bishop captures on
e4 is what you should be playing then
Rook F3 and now the bishop is defended
so you don't have a good move here if
Bishop captures Queen captures again the
bishop is defended uh you're just down
material and you're going to lose this
uh but if you find Knight captures on D3
that's a whole different story now white
can't just play anything because uh
Knight to F4 will Fork the queen and the
King here so Queen to E3 was played or
you capture but that's uh also very bad
as the bishop now Forks the queen and um
and the king so here we have Queen to E3
and now just Queen captures on 4 going
for the queen trade Queen captures
Bishop captures with check and now King
to G3 and now uh there are a couple of
ways you could play this you could
capture this pawn and then um uh after
that uh just just go after this Pawn so
that's possible but instead VI it goes
for King captures on F7 it's still going
to result in him having a bishop and
Knight for a rook but the other way was
maybe a bit more precise Rook captures
we have Bishop to C6 Rook captures on A5
and and now Knight captures on B2 we
have Rook to F5 with check King to E7
and now Rook to E5 with check now jaer
would very much enjoy a Perpetual here
but the vidit says Nope we play on King
to G8 uh Rook to E5 and now Knight to A4
going after the pawn here C4 and again
Knight to B6 going after the pawn here
now you could Advance it all the way to
C5 but then Knight D7 uh attacking um
the rook and the pawn and The Rook will
be uh well you will not be able to keep
defending it as uh The Rook will just
get attacked too much and then you're
going to pick up the pawn so instead
after Knight B6 G5 was played now hoping
for well there's really nothing to hope
for here but maybe if this Pawn gets on
G6 and you get some sort of a rook d8
check uh it maybe could result in
Checkmate of course he's not hoping that
that will happen but maybe he's hoping
that uh a certain position that will
allow a certain tactic that might be
used to make this useful will appear
well that that is possible of course but
King to F7 with this move time control
has been reached Rook to F5 with check
King to E7 and now Rook to E5 check King
to d8 and now Rook to F5 now trying to
go after the king side pawns so King to
E7 and Rook to E5 with check VI will
have to figure out how to go through
this King D6 uh Rook to F5 and now King
to E6 we have Rook to f8 and now Knight
captures on C4 so Rook to h8 going after
the H7 Pawn now comes Knight to D6 uh so
now the Knight is in range of all the
checks so white has to be careful uh
Rook captures on H7 and now Bishop to E4
and that's the idea of course Rook
captures on G7 is impossible because if
you capture it then Knight to F5 check
we'll pick up the uh The Rook here so G6
was played and now we have Pawn to B5
now vid it starts marching forward with
his uh with his pawns King to F4 and now
Pawn to B4 we have um Rook to h8 you
have to get the Rook back into the game
Pawn to B3 you have Rook to B8 always
put a rook behind the pass pawn and now
Bishop to D5 defending the pass pawn and
B3 King E3 and now Pawn to B2 even again
the Knight is in the right place if you
capture of course a fork wins you the
game so uh Pawn to H6 creating a pass
Pawn on the king side but it doesn't
help you all that much you you can't
push because the king just goes after
the pawn so instead King to D4 stopping
the black king from going after the pawn
as the bishop will be hanging but now
just Knight to F5 with check King to C5
and Here pawn to C6 defending the bishop
with Rook captures on B2 but now just
King to F6 and he was in this position
on move 57 death javak snaro resigned
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here uh for those of you who like
it when I show why is that well because
after white play something and there's
really nothing you can play you cannot
do anything here the pawn and Bishop are
guarding themselves El and the King will
capture the pawn on the next move so
that is Unstoppable Rook G2 is
impossible because the bishop covers
that so you're going to have to play
something doesn't matter what the king
will capture the pawn now you're going
to play something else and now the pawn
starts marching forward if you start
going with the King uh King to G5 King
to C3 again the pawn marches forward
even King to G4 if King to D2 Pawn to H4
King to E2 King to G3 and notice that of
course the bishop is covering the
queening square and the King covering
the H2 Square that's pretty much Rook F2
Pawn to H3 and that's it H2 H1 uh White
will have to give up The Rook for this
pawn and then the Knight and Bishop will
be able to escort a pawn or black even
uh if black wants to be fancy about he
can even give up the pawn and then
deliver a knight bishop and King
Checkmate uh so yeah very nicely done by
vidit and with this Victory as a lot of
the other games were drawn vidit is the
soulle leader after seven rounds and uh
will have very very good chances of
actually winning the tournament uh but
his opponent in the next round is Hikaru
Nakamura who is on Five Points so you
know it's going to be it's going to be
tough vid does have the white pieces so
you know it should be should be a great
game vidit will probably play the the
best game he ever played with the white
pieces and he should if he wants to win
this event H but yeah some of the other
pairings Fabby will be facing ATM bakro
as Peno will be facing Vincent kimer
Eric will be facing kuzubov ban Daniel
Dak will be facing vek PR will be facing
f Sean virua Saran raport Aran niman and
chaparo will be facing Duda so those are
the top 10 boards we'll see how it goes
and as usual uh you know use hashtag
suggestion if you want to see some of
the games and even if you want to see
some of the games from the previous
rounds that I haven't covered uh use
also hashtag suggestion I might be able
to cover them after the tournament
finishes uh so yeah that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it very nicely done by
vidit always incredible playing like
that with the black pieces javir always
plays complicated chess and wins this
time he played a bit too complicated uh
it would seem even for himself uh so
yeah once again really hope you enjoyed
it I would like to thank the brers on
Spotify Steven mccan chess beats League
Roma manini and Sam's giant tortois farm
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestions uh and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your
day